[Music]
all right what was every damn day we're
gonna talk about a horse who remembered
Liam Neeson even talking about a 77 pack
of natty ice but first watch this video
this is from Drew Brees last night
playing for the New Orleans Saints he
sets a record here and he's gonna
celebrate but what I want to talk about
is why did he lick his hand after he
threw the football throws the football
demolicious in
why are you doing that what am i I'm
probably casting a spell that's why I
did and so as I alluded to he did this
and he set the all-time NFL passing
record breaking Peyton Manning's record
of 71 thousand nine hundred and forty
yards this is a 100 99 touchdown yeah he
did all of this without endorsing Papa
John's they played a video of paint
Manning after he scored of him like
pretending that he's like cooking a meal
and being like congratulations Drew
Brees I love Twitter exploded too and
all these celebs we're like
congratulations to Drew Brees we're so
proud of you love that celebrities have
to do that too when did they print this
remember the certificate printer on
demand it's also laminated yeah so
either the laminator was also on they
were playing the Redskins and they knew
he would get this yeah
okay
yesterday Chris you mentioned that you
were gonna play some fantasy football
and that you needed Drew Brees to have
him be a good game you came through but
it wasn't enough 71,000 career passing
yards was not enough he broke the record
but not the record Chris could make me
win Chris I asked you yesterday you're
like oh I got a hope Drew Brees has a
good game I said how many points are you
down and you said a hundred you lost the
game he drew the touchdown like a
hundred percent Ernest T you're like
yeah I hope him and Adrian Peterson get
like 50 60 points each then I'll be
alright
sounds like Chris is not so ready to
point I think Drew Brees is celebrating
and when I celebrate I like to throw
back seventy-seven natty ice this is
from the natural ice otherwise known as
the natty light or natty ice a Twitter
account to celebrate the year that they
were created in 1977 they're releasing a
77 pack some might say this is too many
natty you're from say yes I'm from st.
Louis was was natty ice your first beer
yeah absolutely not I had a Budweiser
like a man yeah because I didn't drink
beer till I went to France it's like
look cool that's all you know why they
haven't met France 77 those are that's
on sale for $30 $30 yeah it should be
like I mean it's crazy prices are
arbitrary nothing makes sense my first
my first beer was I had a Miller High
Life because it was called the champagne
my nickname in college was natty ice it
seems like a prank like I would be so
mad College was natty ice or vodka out
of shitty plastic handles
what college did you go to and have you
ever had like gin out of a bathtub the
bag that was like four dollar bag of
slap the bag what's you take a bag of
Franzia and then you slap it and then
you chug as much of it as you can how
much you slap out all right I want to
talk about our next story throw that up
Gillian
we've got the Liam Neeson you know he's
he's the taking guy a horse he worked
with on the ballot of Buster Scruggs
remembered him that's the new Coen
Brothers movie and the exact quote was I
play a traveling impresario we filmed in
New Mexico the odd thing is the horse
who pulls my wagon new me anyone got a
Liam Neeson they want to do that quote
Liam Neeson style
I play a travelling impresario I play it
no it's like Darth Vader guys no you
guys are just going for a joke that was
really good actually if you're jumping
impresario I play a travelling
impresario I play a traveling Bazar EO I
play a traveling and / sorry it's really
hard I know I got it so hard to do but I
got it particle said the horse whinny
dand prams
[Applause]
walk through Central Park all they're
not prancing at all
horse-and-buggy always goes down my
street 1:00 in the morning I'm sure the
show did you happen to wear that I'm
sure everyone in the Internet's looking
at your jacket wait for them to write
things you guys ever worked with animals
yes
yeah I was a tour guide out of Malibu
wine Safari zoo Malibu wines Safari that
sounds like a bad idea it was dangerous
for sure there's alpaca zebras grass and
they're all slap in the bag I was in a
parody video remember that blurred lines
video with like the sexy women walking
around has a no parody video that where
I was naked walking around with comedian
Dan black also naked and we had the hold
goats and it really hurt cuz goats are
really heavy and they like scratched my
naked body with their heads piece of the
animals than a once part mm yeah I
worked at a Whitney's with a giraffe I
sure do
so yesterday during our discussion we
talked about how buff Jordan is getting
and the comment comes from nucking futs
he gave us a time stamp about 1:28 and
wrote salty ryan quickly sizes up jordan
LOL and it was a beautiful catch of ryan
truly going
[Music]
you and wrestle with your eyes yeah I
mean it's just hard work guys you know
just put the time in and the results
will come it's just hard work so
yesterday we led the episode with a
discussion of the recent post fight
brawl between Conor McGregor and khabib
nurmagomedov and now I'm gonna explain
some of it so our key players are Conor
McGregor and Irish born UFC
featherweight and lightweight champion
aka
Charles Manson plus creatine look at
them the resemblance
it's creepy he's up against Habib Nermin
competive a Russian born like myself
Habib is a professional mixed martial
artist aka the youngest member of the
Golden Girls Wow
Habib currently holds the longest
undefeated streak in MMA and his
training has included sparring with a
bear which is actually a common form of
wrestling known as Greco grizzly look it
up it all started at UFC 2 of 5 when
habib was supposed to fight then
champion Eddie Alvarez aka guy whose abs
are full of secrets but the UFC changed
their minds and instead gave the fight
to McGregor Kobe was pissed because his
record was spotless while McGregor had
already lost that year so at a press
conference habib said ireland only has 6
million people russia has 150 million i
want to fight your chicken which is also
how habib places his order for McNuggets
in response McGregor's friend artem blue
buff called Habib a wimp
so Habib did the only thing a non wimp
does and slap Lobo in a hotel lobby
which is how all disputes are settled at
the Licking team in response mcgregor
threw a dolly through Habib's tour bus
window or would the irish call peaceful
mediation mcgregor didn't injure her
beef but he did injure michael Chiesa
AKA guy who just bought new arms i mean
look at this they do not look like his
real arms right those are new arms oh
and on top of that kind of McGregor did
a lot of talking about Abbey's
religion country and family so at the
fight habib came in hot and defeated me
rugger but after the match was over
could be jumped over the cage and went
after McGregor's training partner dylan
Danis aka pirate who sells mixtapes
don't buy one of his tapes it's just him
going at which point Habib's training
partners who I can only assume are two
grown men and a bear and a trenchcoat
scaled the fence and attacked McGregor
and that's where we are in a press
conference post fight habib said his
father will be disappointed but that
putin called to congratulate him I mean
Putin can appreciate her beef skill
Putin himself has never wrestled bears
but he's certainly the horse you know
the photo I'm about to show we all know
it check it out
it's a man and it's very sexy horse I
just explained some of it it's weird
that Marvel has a movie I'd be like
Comedy Central next to me next to this
voice and Liam Neeson's voice you
wouldn't be able to tell the difference
you would definitely be I forget what
Liam Neeson sounds like now that'd be
like if Comedy Central had to show
[Music]